ahora resolvamos el inciso se nos dice
que un bloque 3 de masa 3 que está aquí
se agrega al sistema como se muestra en
la figura de abajo no hay fricción entre
el bloque 3 y la mesa indica si la
magnitud de la aceleración del bloque 2
es más grande más pequeña o igual que en
el sistema de dos bloques explica cómo
llegaste a tu respuesta pensemos en qué
es lo que está sucediendo aquí si
pensamos en las fuerzas netas que actúan
en este sistema como un todo serán las
mismas que teníamos antes pero las
fuerzas internas serán diferentes ya que
tendremos dos cuerdas diferentes y por
lo tanto tendremos dos tensiones
diferentes pero las fuerzas netas que
hacen que esto se acelere hacia arriba
del lado izquierdo hacia la derecha aquí
encima y hacia abajo del lado derecho
siguen ocurriendo debido a la diferencia
entre los pesos de estos dos bloques
pero ahora la diferencia entre el peso
de ambos bloques
más más y sabemos que la fuerza es igual
a la masa por la aceleración o que la
aceleración es igual a la fuerza entre
la masa y con respecto a nuestra fuerza
neta la diferencia entre los pesos de
los bloques ahora estará moviendo una
mayor cantidad de masa esto será m 1 +
m2 + m3 por lo que tendremos una
aceleración más pequeña ahora vamos a
escribir la aceleración
la aceleración disminuye
la aceleración disminuye porque la misma
diferencia porque la misma diferencia
entre los pesos
y m2
ahora está acelerando
una mayor
y cantidad
una mayor cantidad de masa
y esta es la explicación intuitiva de lo
que pasa aquí y si quisieran ver esto
más a fondo podrían hacer un diagrama de
cuerpo libre para cada uno de estos
bloques y llegarán a la misma conclusión
de hecho vamos a hacerlo para sentirnos
bien con nosotros mismos vamos a dibujar
las fuerzas en la masa 1 tenemos la
fuerza de gravedad m 1 por g vamos a
tener la fuerza de tensión hacia arriba
que va a ser mayor que la fuerza de
gravedad
la dibujamos en otro color de 1 les
llamamos t 1 porque ahora vamos a tener
dos tensiones diferentes porque tenemos
dos cuerdas diferentes aquí tenemos de 1
y por acá también tendremos a t 1 porque
es la misma cuerda y la atención tendrá
la misma magnitud el bloque 2 tiene una
masa más grande que la del bloque 1 y
por lo tanto su peso será mayor todo el
sistema se va a acelerar a la derecha
del lado derecho se va a acelerar hacia
abajo
la parte de arriba se va a acelerar a la
derecha y la parte de la izquierda se va
a acelerar hacia arriba si la parte de
arriba se acelera hacia la derecha
entonces la atención que hay entre la
segunda cuerda será más grande que la
atención que hay en la primera cuerda
vamos a dibujarlo en otro color esto es
de 2 y la atención en este otro lado de
la cuerda también será de 2 porque la
magnitud de la atención a lo largo de
una misma cuerda será la misma
finalmente tenemos el peso del bloque 2
que va a ser mayor que esta tensión m2
porque aquí dibujé todas las fuerzas que
son relevantes para la magnitud de la
aceleración si fuera a graficar un
diagrama completo de cuerpo libre nos
enfocaríamos en m 1 m 3 y m 2 y hay más
fuerzas actuando en m3 en la dirección
vertical una en su peso m 3 por g pero
no se está acelerando hacia abajo porque
la mesa está ejerciendo
fuerza sobre este bloque hacia arriba de
la misma magnitud para equilibrar su
peso y esto es lo que hacemos por si
quieren tener un diagrama de cuerpo
libre más completo pero para este
problema nos interesan sólo aquellas
fuerzas que se mueven en la dirección de
la aceleración dependiendo de en donde
nos encontremos en la mesa por lo que
podemos usar la segunda ley de newton
como lo hicimos antes las fuerzas netas
en cierta dirección dada son iguales a
la masa por la magnitud de la
aceleración para el bloque 1 usaremos
este color cuáles son sus fuerzas netas
de 1 - m 1 por g va a ser igual a m 1 x
qué hay del bloque 3 se va a acelerar
hacia la derecha
vamos a usar otro color aquí tenemos de
2 menos de 1 igual a m3 por a y la
magnitud de la aceleración va a ser la
misma
aquí aceleramos hacia la derecha aquí
aceleramos hacia arriba y aquí
aceleramos hacia abajo pero las
magnitudes serán las mismas y las
denotamos con esta a minúscula y
finalmente vamos a ver las fuerzas netas
en el bloque 2 m2 por g menos de 2 que
va en sentido opuesto a m2 por g y esto
es igual a m2 por a y si ahora queremos
despejar la aceleración podemos sumar
todos los lados izquierdos para tener un
nuevo lado izquierdo y sumar todos los
lados derechos para tener un nuevo lado
derecho podemos hacer esto algebraica
mente porque esto es igual a esto esto
es igual a esto y esto es igual a esto
si sumamos todos estos y sumamos todos
aquellos
entonces las sumas serán iguales entre
sí así que vamos a tener este 1 se
cancela cuando le restamos esta t1
estate 2 se va a cancelar cuando le
restemos estate 2 y nos vamos a quedar
con esta m2 por g - m 1 por g
y esto va a ser igual a m 1 x mas m 3 x
mas m2 por a podemos factorizar la a por
lo que podemos escribir esto como a por
m 1 más m2 más m3 y dividimos ambos
lados entre m 1 más m2 más m3 lo hacemos
esto entre m 1 más m2 más m3 y esto
entre m 1 más m2 más m3 estas se
cancelan y esta es la magnitud de
nuestra aceleración noten que tenemos la
misma diferencia entre los pesos que nos
proporcionan la fuerza neta en el
sistema pero ahora van a estar
acelerando una mayor cantidad de masa
aquí señalamos que es una mayor una
mayor cantidad mayor cantidad de masa
mayor cantidad de masa que hay que
acelerar tengo la misma fuerza neta
actuando en el sistema ya que todas las
fuerzas internas se cancelaron cuando
sume estas ecuaciones
por lo que si tenemos la misma fuerza
neta y la dividimos entre una masa más
grande
tendremos una aceleración más pequeña
espero que esto tenga sentido para
ustedes